セーローヤターエーカガノー ワーテーナナ サミーラティ
エーワン ニンダーパサンサースー ナサミンジャンティ パンディター
これの意味は このセーローっていうのは石のこと
エーカガノーっていうのはかなり一つの塊になっている
まあすごい大きな石なんですね
何と言いますか ロックというね
英語でね 岩ですね ものすごい
ひび割れいっぱいある岩ではなくて
しっかり一つの塊になっているすごい岩
ワーテーナナ サミーラティ
風が吹いたんだからといって揺れることはないんだと
動かないんですね 風が吹いても
でっかい岩なら エーワン
このようにニンダーパサンサースー
ニンダーは非難 侮辱 パサンサーっていうのは褒めること
非難されても褒められても
ナサミンジャンティ パンディター
賢者は揺らぎませんと
智慧のある人は まあ侮辱しても褒められても
岩のごとくいるんですと
なんか面白くない偈のように感じるでしょう
しかし これすごい意味なんですよ
だから賢者ならそうなんですよとブッダが言うんです
岩のごとくいるんだよと
人が非難したんだからといって
別にどうったことはない
痛くも痒くもないんです
じゃあ褒めたんだからといって
一般の愚か者が褒められたっても
痛くも痒くもないんです
だからそこが大事なポイントなんです
批判したければどうぞという感じでいないと
だからこの真理を知っている人は
いかに動じないというか
強いかということ で オウム真理教の人々はもう日本国民みんな殺そうと企んでいて
何よこれと 自分の教えが正しいすごいものだったら
別に気にしなくていいでしょうに
一般人がもう何言ったって
ちょっと批判しただけで
弁護士は家族ごとにもう誘拐して殺すと
子供まで だからここでブッダが人格者の世界を教えているんです
動じないんだよと 何をやっても
あ そう ニコッと笑って終わるんです
だから我々にはそれできるのは
我々も人格的にしっかりしているならば
真理の人であるならば
すごくその強さが出てくるんです
面白かった事件がありまして
あの こちらの事務所へ引っ越すする前に
あの目白っていうところで
あの小さなところでいたんです
で そこをあの駅の前 大きい道路があって
よく私はそこら辺で買い物したり
もうそっちを行ったり来たりして
そこら辺教会あるんですね
あの教会っていったって
まあシスターたちばっかりですからと思いますけど
たまに行く時はその人々もね
買い物やらいろいろ用事があったりして
まあ出かけて会ったりはします
いわゆる 別に会うことではないんだけど
私は見ただけで怯えて走るは走るは
逃げるは逃げるは あの格好悪さ
もうだって頭上から全部なんか変な装飾の服装を着てるでしょう
私はお前らの信仰はその程度かと
結局信仰してないだろうと
ちゃんと神を信仰しているならば
私たちはサタンの教えかもしれませんだけどね
サタン本人に会ったっても怖くないでしょうに
たとえサタンの教えをやっていたっても
ただの人間でしょうに
人間に顔を合わせる勇気がないんだから
だからそれを見るたびに私は面白くて面白くて
また時間計って行った方がいいなとかね
この日本人としても情けないでしょうに
ああいうことをやっていることさえもね
なおさら惨めにしてやるかなとも
なかなか暇がなくてね
だから学生でいた時だったらね
結構いろんなことができたのにと
いくらでも自由な時間がありましたからね
だからね 自分の国にイスラムの人々は別に私を見ても何のことなく随分親しくしますけど
他のところで時々見たらもう震えて十字架
十字 宇宙船とか自分と投げたり重ねてるんですね
こいつら何者かと思いますけど
だから怯えていることを自分と投げているんだっていうことだけ私は読み取れるんですね
だからそれが面白くて
ああ 偉大なる宗教の人やと
結局は自分の神を信仰してないんだと
なのにこちらにセンターがありますから
そちらにごく一般的なイスラムの人々を祈りに行くんですけど
行ってみたら 私も外人
そちらも外人で 私も宗教の人
こちらも宗教のことに何のことなくニコッと挨拶して
一言葉交わしたりして
もう人間らしく この人々は立派やと
別に怖くて怖くなる必要も何もなく
これはある別な宗教の人
あれは別な宗教の人で
じゃあこんにちはと そういう人々にとっては
自分のやっていることには正しいかどうか本人分かってないんだけど
一応それなりに自信を持ってやっているんですよ
だからこの 真理を知るとね
すごい強さが出てくるんです
別に人が何言われてもそんなこと気になる？だから仏教ははっきりと真理を知っている人は動じませんよと
褒められても 侮辱されたっても
もうそれにニコッとしているんだと
だから仏教はなぜ世の中に広ま知ってますか？みんな非難しているんだからなんです
西洋ででしょ 仏教は研究してたのは
皆様も西洋の奴隷だから
西洋で広げてるんだから
仏教に興味持ったでしょうに
アメリカに行ったら イギリスに行ったら
フランス行こう ドイツに行こう
結構ありますよ 大乗仏教っていうのは日本から行って作ってあるんだけど
生きているところといえばテーラワーダ仏教のお寺ですね
ドイツ人も自分たちでやってるし
イギリス人がイギリス人でお寺やったりしているし
それからもう年二年からもね
研究もしているし みんなキリスト教の方々なんですよ
牧師さんやら神父さんやらお金も教会出したんです
あの邪言をね あの悪魔の教えを
君たちはちゃんと勉強して
もういかに間違っているかというのを広げなさいと
それでお寺に行ったら
はい どうぞと本を開けるんです
わからないんだったら
もう授業もタダで無料で教えてあげるんです
お寺で今もね お寺に行って何とか教えてくださいと言ったら
毎週金曜日だけで大丈夫ですよ
お金取りません はいどうぞと喜んで教えてあげるんです
今も だから じゃあ論文書き書いてくださいと
まあ書くんですけど どうなったかというと
そんなもんです だから結局広げてしまっただけ
神父さんも隠れてブッダを信仰することになるだけ
だからもう真理の世界は別に怖くないんです
自分の国でも ちょっと一般人に対しては
すごい坊さんたちも同じですけど
あのちょっとインテリ系でないとね
もうやることっていうのはちょっと信頼できませんしね
例えば あのあの これまあ
キリスト教かイスラム教かどちらかわかりませんだけど
仏教を侮辱するために
この女性の Tシャツとパンツとか
ブッダの顔をね 仏画を
それを印刷して売ったりするんです
で まあそれは一般人から見ればね
わざとやっていることだからね
まあわざと侮辱しようと
で おしゃれだったら別なんですけどね
これにすごいもう何て言いますか
反乱ではなく 何て言いますか
まあ批判してね まあ国際的にも人の宗教信仰を侮辱することはやめなさいということで
わざと侮辱することは良くないんだと
意図的に でも仏教は批判が禁止ということじゃなくて
そうやってもうすごい気持ち悪い
わざと人の気持ちを傷つくようなことをやめなさいということで
まあ国際的に決めて法律まで作ったりして
まあ私はそこまでやるのかとも
女の人のパンツの後ろにね
ブッダの顔があったって
もう勝手にしろよと それで誰が不幸になるか分かるんだから
それで壊れる仏教じゃないでしょうに
私はそういう立場なんですよ
言うとまずいんだからね
こちらもどこかでレストランでね
飲み屋さんですけど 前にでっかい仏像をつけちゃったりして
それが宣伝なんですね
あまり 私は見たんですけど
もうしちゃったんで もうそこで行ったらもう必ずスリランカは文句を言って
日本の政府にね それ取り外してもらうんですよ
それは良くないと だから仏教はすごい論理的に正しく言うんだから断れないんです
暴動は起したりしません
ちゃんと法律的に 論理的に
こういうことは良くないと
別に外で仏像あったっても何のこともないんです
あっちこっちあったって
それに何も店の看板に
またなおさら飲み屋さんにね
使ったりするのは中国から持ってきた何かだと思いますけどね
私は見て別にやってくださいという感じで
で なんか音楽グループいるでしょ
ニルヴァーナという 何のニルヴァーナもないんですけど
麻薬ばっかりだったり
もう聞いたら頭がイカれるような音楽なんですけど
どうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
ニルヴァーナという名前のレストランもあるし
何か系列もありますよ
そういうことに興奮する？別に
そう 別に冷静でいればいいんです
そんなことで壊れる仏教じゃないんです
だからこの真理を知っている人
真理の人っていうのはすごく動じないでいるというね
優柔不断がないし 人が批判したことだからといって
キャーキャーキャーって
なんかもう犬猫みたいにね
攻撃にはいかないし 褒めたんだからって言って何でもあげるぞとかね
それもないし あんまり褒めると仏教の人々の反応知ってますかね
そこまで褒めてくれると何かあげなくちゃいけないんですねと言うんです
それで相手がすぐ黙ってるんです
すごく明るくて動じないんです
そこ大事なポイントなんですよ
現状 世界の現代の状況を見ると
昔の状況を見ると もう一旦認めなかったんで殺しちゃったんです
戦争までして まぁ この神を信じる宗教の歴史はもう殺し歴史なんです
ヒンドゥー教も一応やらないんだけど
もう思想としては戦争宗教なんですね
戦うことをすごく正当化するんです
このかなり世界でヘンテコリンでね
あべこべでふやかしているバガヴァッドギーターという本がありますね
あれはヒンドゥー教 仏教のダンマパダと似ているレベルのものだと
全然似てないんですけど
バガヴァッドギーターは何やということより
戦争しなさい 戦いなさいという話
たったそれだけなんです
ガチャガチャ言わずに戦いなさいと
相手を殺しなさいという話ですよ
何の道徳もないんです
だから神の定めだと思って殺せば
それこそ神に対するカルマヨーガでヨーガであると
私が殺しちゃったと思っちゃうと
あなたは自我を持ってきて殺人の罪を犯しているんだというポイントな論理は
あれって道徳ですかね
よくも丸っきり道徳否定していて
殺したい放題殺せという教えがすごい道徳的なテキストだとみんな褒めてるでしょう
世界は どこまであべこべかと
じゃあ私が言うことを嘘やと思うならば
日本訳でもいいんだから
なんとなく読んでみてください
深い分析に行かなくていいんです
普通の常識で読んでみてください
何書いてるのかと まぁ美しい詩ですよ
作品としては結構立派な作品です
しかし 論点は何なのかというと
自我を出すなよと 自我を出したら罪であって
自我さえ出さないならば
もう大量殺人でもOKであるという話なんです
これは決まりだからやらなくちゃと
自分がクシャトリヤ職に生まれたんだから
私はクシャトリヤ職にしたのは神様だと
だから神様が決めた義務であると
やらいこっちゃ だから殺すんです
そういう論点なんです
[笑い]だからこの神を信じるっていう宗教っていうのは
すごい人を殺したり殺したり戦争したりいきますよ
だから真理じゃなく真理がなくなると
真理がない場合はその弱みがあるんです
神といったっても 証拠は不可能ではなくて
成り立たない概念だから
これやばいんですよ だからもうかなりごまかし
いろいろ脅ししなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それでこのジャイナ教は神をない神がないんだから
殺しは全く一切の理由があっても認めません
仏教は神がいないんだから
一切の理由があっても殺しは認めないだけではなくて
もう批判しても放っておいてくださいと批判されても
個人的にはっきりと攻撃してくると返事はします
それは怒って殺すそうではなくて
まあ論理的にあんたこう言いますけど
これはこういうこういうことであると
いうふうなことで反論はする
それ以外はケンカはしません
特に論理的な哲学と思想的な争論というのはケンカではないんだから
それは知識世界で起こることだから
それには一応応じます
逃げたりはしません 出てこいと言ったら出て行く
あんた方の教えはあんな正しければ出てこいと私は批判するぞと言ったら
我々は堂々と行くんです
しかし あの連中はなんだよと言ったって別に感情的に言うことには何のことなく
あんた紅茶一杯いかがでしょうかと
疲れたでしょうとか そういう態度なんです
そういうことで この大事な面白くない芸じゃないんです
遠い昔からもうね お釈迦様が人間のあるべき姿を教えているはずなんです
現代でもその人間でしょ
必要なのは 批判されても褒めたっても
あれ気にしないで冷静で動じないでいる人々なんです
未来にしたってそういう人間でしょ
必要な そういうことってとても大事な経典なんです
で あの お釈迦様の弟子一人がいたんです
ラクントカ・バッディアという名前の
名前はバッディアなんです
ラクントカっていうのはおそらくあだ名というかね
ちょっと失礼な言葉やと思います
この人が体がすごく小さいんです
このお坊さんは 小さいと言ったっても
ある何かある程度体成長しないという問題があるですね
だから年取っても取っても
小学生の小学生の背の高さしか伸びないとかね
今もいますからね だから体見たら子供みたく見えるんですけど
大人は大人なんです この方は出家して修行してもう悟っているんです
しかし 誰も知らない それは
これで沙弥たちがやりたい放題
からかいたい放題 ラクントカっていうのは
ミジェットという英語でいうミジェッ
ミジェットっていうんですけど
日本語で何て言うか  小人
小人 という ちょっと失礼なあだ名なんですね
一応今は正式名になってますけど
このお坊さん大やらかんの
だからいろいろいじったりからかったり
みんな笑ったりするんですけど
このお坊さんが別に全然何の反応もないんです
だから中に入るとみんなあ
ミジェットが来たとか言われたって
別に全然もう聞いてないような感じで自分座るところに座って
指をさしたり 指さしたり
いじったりしたって あんなことなくいる
だから全然問題起きません
喧嘩にもなりませんし
話題にもなりません それで終了するんです
みんなにからかわれているのに
からかう側にしても 何か問題とかね
自分の師匠たちに怒られたとかね
全然ない 別に問題は起きません
それでそこはあんまりもうひどいんだから
お釈迦様はそのところにさっさと行って
まああんた方は何の騒ぎをしているのかと聞いたんです
どんな騒ぎでしょうかと
言っちゃうと もうどうしようもなく
実はのお釈迦様は この人は我々がいろいろ言ってからかうんだけど
泳いだとしてもシャムみたいですけどね
全然なんか変ですよと
怒ったりも怒鳴ったりも何のこともないんだよと
おかしいと 体だけじゃなくて
これ何遍もそう言われると
そういう人に限ってすごく怒ったりしますからね
ただ お釈迦様 それはそうでしょうと
大阿羅漢は崖のごとく動じませんよと
賢者は そこで問題は最終的にもう阿羅漢からかったらもう大罪だからね
それも言わないで もうお釈迦様は随分見事に賢者は崖のごとく動じませんよと
で お釈迦様の仲間にしたんですね
それから位もいただきましたけどね
それからそれっきり みんなもう一番先に行かせていただくだけで
まあからかうことはなくなったんです
だから そういう個人的なエピソードかもしれませんだけど
ブッダの言葉がそこから抜けて普遍的に過去現在未来に通じるように
お釈迦様は語るんです
そのポイント それがブッダたる所以なんです
だから我々はラコンタ・ブッダディーア大阿羅漢のエピソードを知っても知らなくても
ポイントは生き生きしています
それはそういうことで
今日の話は終了したいと思います